la primera vez que te encuentras con
combinaciones y permutaciones cuesta
bastante trabajo y en estos casos lo que
yo he visto es que lo mejor es hacer
muchísimos ejemplos así es que aquí
vamos a ver otra vez un ejemplo de
permutaciones y combinaciones pero vamos
a ir un poquito más allá vamos a empezar
repasando lo que vimos y voy a seguir
utilizando el ejemplo de las personas y
las sillas pero en los próximos vídeos
vamos a cambiar de ejemplo y ya no van a
ser personas sentando sencillas por el
momento tenemos a las personas a d
d
efe y únicamente tenemos cuatro sillas
la silla 12
y 4 y bueno eso ya lo hemos visto un
montón de veces para sacar el número de
permutaciones de seis personas en cuatro
sillas lo que hacemos es poner aquí
cuántas personas podemos poner en la
silla uno podemos poner seis personas
para cada uno de esos escenarios tenemos
cinco personas que podrían sentarse aquí
porque una de las seis personas ya está
sentada en la silla 1 y para estos 35
posibles escenarios tenemos 4
posibilidades porque hay 4 personas que
se podrían sentar aquí y luego para
estos 120 escenarios tenemos tres
opciones que es el número de personas
que podrían sentarse aquí así es que 6
por 5 por 4 por 3 es el número de
permutaciones y como vimos en el vídeo
de la fórmula para las permutaciones
esto de aquí se puede escribir como 6
factorial que bueno todavía no termino
pero el 6 factorial es 6 por 5 por 4 por
3 por 2 por 1
ahora en esta multiplicación en este
factorial realmente con lo que nos
queremos que ver es con los primeros 4
factores que no queremos esta parte de
aquí y lo que hacemos para quitar estos
actores que no nos sirven es decir ok
queremos los primeros cuatro lugares
entonces vamos a dividir entre 6
- 4 y tomamos el factorial y este
factorial de aquí lo que hace es empezar
a multiplicar a partir de aquí es un 6
menos 4 2 factorial 2 por 1 y entonces
este 2 por 1 se cancela con este 2 por 1
y nos queda 6 por 5 por 4 por 3 que es
el número de permutaciones de seis
personas en cuatro lugares que yo estoy
fue un repaso rápido de la fórmula para
las permutaciones que si las recordamos
aquí tenemos las permutaciones de n
k
y la fórmula nos dice que la cantidad de
permutaciones de n cosas en cada lugar
es es en el factorial entre n menos k
factorial solo que de cambio le pongo
colores adecuados esta acaba en verde
y la cantidad de cosas las estamos
poniendo con este rosa
y luego nos fuimos el mundo de las
combinaciones y en las combinaciones no
nos importa el orden en el que están
sentadas las personas aquí en las
permutaciones si nos importa mucho el
orden de hecho si tenemos por aquí a a b
y de esta es una permutación pero si
tenemos de a b c esta de aquí es otra
permutación aunque ya estamos contando a
estos dos como dos permutaciones
distintas aunque son dos de las cosas
que estamos contando aquí que por cierto
este número de aquí es treinta por doce
y eso es 360 360 y de estos 360
esta es una permutación y esta es otra
permutación pero en el mundo de las
combinaciones como aquí tenemos
exactamente las mismas personas sentadas
estos dos contarían únicamente como una
combinación justo porque no nos importa
el orden en el que están sentadas
entonces cuando tenemos las
combinaciones
n en cada cuando tenemos n personas de
las cuales vamos a escoger a cada
personas para que se sienten en algún
lugar y queremos saber cuántas
combinaciones de cada personas podemos
obtener lo que hacemos es buscar cuántas
permutaciones de n en acá tenemos o sea
tenemos que poner por aquí n factorial
entre n menos k factorial y luego
tenemos que dividir entre la cantidad de
formas en las que podemos ordenar a las
personas sentadas y otra vez yo me
acuerdo que la primera vez que aprendí
esto de las combinaciones me costó un
montón de trabajo que ellas y es que
tómatelo con calma si te parece muy
confuso al principio piénsalo y vas a
ver cómo eventualmente te va a aparecer
súper claro porque ya que escogimos
cuáles son las personas que se van a
sentar las permutaciones están tomando
en cuenta todas las formas en las que se
pueden ordenar esas
y nosotros en las combinaciones queremos
que todas estas permutaciones cuenten
como un solo objeto entonces por eso
tenemos que dividir entre la cantidad de
formas de arreglar a las mismas cuatro
personas o bueno más bien la cantidad de
formas de ordenar a cada personas
sentadas
así es que algo que tenemos que saber es
cuál es el número de formas
por mes de ordenar
ordenar acá cosas
cosas
acá lugares y te recomiendo que lo
pongas una pausa y lo pienses porque de
hecho esto de aquí es lo que vimos en el
primer vídeo de permutaciones ok bueno
entonces tenemos acá lugares lugar 1
lugar 2 lugar 3 y así nos seguimos hasta
que llegamos al lugar acá y nos
preguntamos cuántas cosas podemos poner
en el lugar número uno pues tenemos que
cosas así es que tenemos acá
posibilidades y luego cuántas opciones
tenemos para el lugar 2 pues ya pusimos
una cosa en el lugar 1 así es que nos
quedan que a menos un opciones y por
aquí tenemos acá menos dos cosas
si nos seguimos hasta que llegamos al
lugar acá y qué opciones tenemos aquí
pues ya pusimos casi todas las cosas
solo nos queda una cosa tenemos una
opción ya ver qué es lo que nos quedó
pues lo que tenemos aquí es que porque
al menos uno porque al menos dos y así
hasta llegar al 1 entonces esto de aquí
es k factorial la cantidad de formas de
ordenar k cosas en qué lugares es k
factorial la cantidad de formas de
ordenar cuatro cosas en cuatro lugares
es 4 factorial la cantidad de
permutaciones de tres cosas en tres
lugares es 3 factorial y así sucede con
todos los números así es que por aquí
tenemos que dividir entre cada factorial
y entonces lo que nos queda es n
factorial en el factorial entre cada
factorial
que factorial por n k factorial n - k
factorial y listo esta es la fórmula de
las combinaciones de nn k mccray donde
de un grupo de n cosas escogemos k sin
nada y ya esto de aquí también se le
conoce como la fórmula de los
coeficientes binomial es y sobre todo en
estos casos se los denota como n en cada
y a veces se les conoce como de n escoge
que por las combinaciones de n en k o
simplemente n en k pero bueno aquí ya lo
vimos todo de forma muy abstracta así es
que regresemos a nuestro ejemplo con
seis personas y cuatro lugares lo que
vimos al principio es que si tenemos
seis personas y queremos sentar las en
orden en cuatro sillas tenemos 360
formas de hacerlo ahora
y no nos importa el orden en el que se
sientan las personas si simplemente
queremos escoger a cuatro personas
entonces lo que necesitamos son las
combinaciones de seis en cuatro que
queremos las combinaciones tenemos un
grupo de seis personas y sólo queremos
escoger a cuatro que se puedan sentar ok
si tenemos seis personas cuantas
combinaciones de cuatro personas podemos
formar y otra forma de ver esto es poner
por aquí las combinaciones de seis en
cuatro o sea si tenemos seis personas
cuántas formas hay de escoger a cuatro
de esas personas mccray de seis escojo
cuatro y bueno entonces aquí tenemos que
volver a pensar todo lo que pensamos
aquí o aplicar la fórmula pero te repito
eso de aplicar la fórmula no es tan
buena idea de hecho yo cuando tengo que
acordarme de esta fórmula y ha pasado
mucho tiempo en realidad en lugar de
irme a buscar esta fórmula en algún
lugar
vuelvo a pensar ok que es lo que quiero
y hago todo este razonamiento otra vez
porque simplemente memorizar esta
fórmula es una forma de no aprenderla
realmente pero ahorita que ya sabemos
qué es lo que hay de fondo las
combinaciones de seis personas escoger
cuatro son n factorial pero bueno aquí
ya no tenemos en el factorial tenemos un
6 factorial ok tenemos seis personas 6
factorial entre la cantidad de lugares
factorial 4 factorial por la cantidad de
personas menos la cantidad de lugares
menos 4 factorial y entonces aquí lo que
tenemos es 6 factorial entre 4 factorial
y esto de aquí que bueno es esto de aquí
que proviene de esta parte de las
permutaciones pues es 6 menos 4
2 factoriales y desarrollamos estos
factoriales y nos queda 6 por 5 por 4
por 3 por 2 por 1 entre 4 factorial que
es 4 por 3 por 2 por 1 y luego por dos
factores que es 2 por 1 y entonces esta
parte de aquí 4 por 3 por 2 por 1 se
cancela con esta parte de aquí 4 por 3
por 2 por 1 por aquí este 1 no aporta
nada a la multiplicación y aquí tenemos
un 6 que puede ser dividido entre 2
entonces 6 entre 2 nos queda 3 y lo que
nos queda es 3 por 5 que es
15 great tenemos 15 combinaciones la
cantidad de combinaciones de seis
personas en cuatro lugares es 15 por
aquí lo que obtuvimos es que la cantidad
de permutaciones la cantidad de formas
de acomodar a seis personas en cuatro
lugares tomando en cuenta el orden en el
que se sientan es 360 permutaciones pero
las combinaciones de seis en cuatro son
únicamente 15 y eso sucede porque de las
mismas cuatro personas las permutaciones
están tomando en cuenta todas las formas
de ordenarse mientras que para las
combinaciones siempre que sean las
mismas 4 personas no importa cómo se
sienten tenemos un mismo objetos es una
misma combinación de cuatro personas
entonces si tenemos una combinación de
cuatro personas ya vimos que son cuatro
factorial permutaciones para encontrar
la cantidad de combinaciones de seis en
cuatro tomamos las permutaciones de seis
en cuatro
y las dividimos entre 4 factorial porque
para cada grupo de 4 personas tenemos 4
factorial permutaciones pero una sola
combinación ok es este mismo 4 factorial
de aquí y este mismo 4 por 3 por 2 por 1
y como estamos dividiendo entre 4
factorial que es 24 entonces por eso nos
queda 15 ok tal cual lo que hacemos es
tomar el número de permutaciones 360 y
dividirlo entre 24 y nos quedan 15
combinaciones y finalmente de dónde
viene esta fórmula pues este pedazo de
aquí viene directamente de las
permutaciones que realmente solo aporta
el 6 por 5 por 4 por 3 que realmente lo
que hace es de estas seis personas
escoger y ordenar 4 y lo último que nos
falta es este 4 factorial que lo que nos
está diciendo es que realmente no le
importa el orden lo único que queremos
es d
a seis personas escoger cuatro estamos
dividiendo entre el número de formas en
los que podemos ordenar a cuatro cosas
en cuatro espacios ok
número de permutaciones entre número de
formas de ordenar a cuatro cosas en
cuatro lugares